on l'a déjà fait avec cadres devraient
le faire avec dany dany venez me
rejoindre
je sais que les téléspectateurs je sais
que les téléspectateurs adorent cette
séquence c'est très simple et novateur
une paire et les maîtres des perruques
rire est une perruque 4 va vous appeler
on va le faire chacun notre tour
ces deux duels des perruques celui que
voilà et juste vous vous retournez va
juste vous appelez pas faire juste dany
et là vous vous retournez tout
simplement on va démarrer la nuit avec
cette période cas d'appel très bien les
gens à tokyo dany c'est à vous pour
l'appeler et vous êtes attention à temps
et demi
j'attaque survivre
le gars qui baisse la musique que plus
lentement du monde y est comme ça un
attentat près shirin louis achille
oui ce que la menace était crédible
attention a dit vraiment on écrivait en
effet je suis jeune est-ce que alice
vous m'appellerez après c'est vous qui
dites est vrai je suis prof et demi oui
baird
peut être qu'ils adorent toile il m'a
surpris c'est aujourd'hui par apple toi
comédie ouais ça c'était comptable adore
1-2 3-1
oui
agnès connat comme ça là ça va être pas
mal aussi
vous avez parlé de biercée daddy qui va
parler de derrière sur la tête d'un
rival à tapairu ilan pappé rococo ou
avec ce n est pas mal attention une amie
qui venait je suis prêt tiens gérard tu
l'appelles date après année oui quoi
c'est le gardien on dirait qu'ils c'est
la tête qui va gagner une petite
carrière et petit verdot
mais c'est vrai qu'on dirait qu'il sait
la tête ce qui désirait déjà que le
personnage du gars comme la tension
vient il à pédalage ali sadisme à
l'aller 1 2 3 danny way